this is
[Applause]
Bad Bunny passionately sings his heart
out to Ariana Grande it's a very
exciting thing for us and Harry Styles
[Music]
I always
put my my a piece of my heart on
everything that I do the Puerto Rican
Superstar is the latest guest to ride
shotgun with James Corden on carpool
karaoke the two first kick things off
with bad Bunny's hit song dakitially
[Music]
I'm very grateful that the world can
connect with my music even when I'm in
Singing in my language Spanish a lot of
people don't don't speak Spanish but
love my music so I'm very grateful for
that and when Ari's 2014 track Break
Free comes on Bad Bunny doesn't hold
back I think this is the most the the
English sound that I most know the
lyrics yeah because I I listen to
English music I like but I never this is
[Applause]
[Music]
do whatever you want whatever you want
whatever feels natural be yourself jam
session aside Bad Bunny also opens up
about his other passion wrestling I love
wrestling since ever since since I was a
kid in my songs I have a lot of
wrestling reference then the rapper
shows James a thing or two in the ring
what's a good move yo take a seat okay
okay
off but then while I'm here I'm like
as the carpool comes to an end things
were not the same when Harry's as it was
began playing
[Music]
you have to kind of think about what's
what's more important it's no surprise
Bad Bunny knows the lyrics to Harry's
hits the rapper was spotted at the
former One Direction singers concert in
LA back in January
and how's this for Six Degrees of
Separation Bad Bunny just so happens to
be spending time with Kendall Jenner who
previously dated Harry just be cool it's
fine last week A source told E.T Kendall
and Bad Bunny real name Benito Ocasio or
taking things slow and seeing where
things go in the future they both really
like each other and are just hanging out
and having a good time I'm a good guy
I'm cute
laughs
[Music]